Warren Moon through as pretty a deep
ball as anybody I've ever seen Jeff
George was another one who threw a great
deep ball horns were usually caught
though as opposed to Jeff George's and
the hall-of-famer joining us on the
program good morning Warren how are you
that's not did have a talented arm
though man you can throw it from every
angle from every platform I love
watching him throw the football most
physically town at quarterback you've
ever seen Wow
we got to go by errors like John Elway
was pretty physically talented during
the time that I play you look now at
Patrick my Holmes I mean it's physically
talented he is also Aaron Rodgers there
was a bit there's been a lot of them so
I don't know it's hard to say one but
those guys that I just named are pretty
much in that same class where they can
throw the ball from any angle any
platform feet don't have to be together
one of them threw the ball with his left
hand in a game and then a completed one
so that tells you how talented those
guys are how helpless is that feeling
when you're on the sidelines and you're
watching a quarterback lead that
two-minute drill and there's nothing you
can do believe me I've been there cuz I
remember in Denver you know we got gave
the ball back to John Elway with a
minute 48 left on his own five-yard line
and I'm sitting on the sidelines hoping
our defense can get them stopped so we
can win this playoff game and he takes
them down converts to fourth down
situations and ends up going down and
getting the final score to beat us so
there was nothing I could do over on
that sideline as you said because my job
if anything I could've got one more
first down and hopefully ran the clock
out but that didn't happen so there's
nothing you can do if you don't play
defense when you came out of Washington
and you had an unbelievable Rose Bowl
performance but why were you told you
weren't drafted you know a lot of
different reasons it had nothing to do
with the real reason I think you know
they said I didn't come out of a
pro-style offense they said that a lot
of teams who never even came out to look
at me thought I was wasn't tall enough I
wasn't big enough you know I'm the same
same height as I am right
now probably 205 pounds at the time
which which I think was pretty big
enough to play quarterback and just a
lot of different reasons it didn't make
a whole lot of sense but the biggest
thing I think was they said that I
didn't come out of a pro-style offense
and we didn't run a pro-style offense
but that didn't mean that I couldn't
navigate into a pro-style offensive
that's what I was asked to do I ran the
offenses that I was asked to run and
that's what we're good quarterbacks can
do they can make adjustments to
different types of styles if they have
an ability that they need to play the
position and playing the position for as
long as you did there were code words
that you would hear that would mean
something they would it would mean more
to you than it would mean because
they're saying late you didn't run a
pro-style offense not that you couldn't
adapt to run a pro-style offense but all
of a sudden we've labeled you know Cam
Newton didn't run a pro-style offense
no but lots of guys didn't run close to
tal offenses but there's guys that ran
option offenses in college but they
still win and he still got a chance to
play in the NFL
at least show what they could do so I
wasn't taking that and even Doug
Williams who ran a pro-style offense at
Grambling the year I came out he was he
was a first-round draft pick but he was
he went to Tampa Bay which was John
Mackay at the time and John Mackay at
African American quarterbacks a bunch at
USC so he was used to to having an
african-american quarterback but if Doug
wouldn't have win at 13 which was 13th
pick he should have went before that but
he but he went to 13 if he doesn't go to
Tampa Bay at 13 he might not have went
the first round either so mmm that's
just that that's just the time that we
lived in there was a mentality and a
stigma about african-american
quarterbacks and I knew it was gonna be
difficult for me to play that position
when I chose to do it so it didn't
surprise me when things got a little
more difficult as I got into college you
hear this conversation now where people
are saying hey maybe it's time to give
Colin Kaepernick a chance I just wonder
is it a legitimate chance for he's gonna
want to start I think everything he's
gone through you don't want to go back
into the NFL and say okay hey we gave
you your job now go away
you should be happy he's a competitor
like anybody is he wants to start but do
you think Kaepernick why now is somebody
gonna give him a chance when he hasn't
played in four years
that now we give him a chance in how do
you think he would accept that
opportunity yeah I think the only way he
should be given a chance is that if he
can go through a workout for a team and
pass their workout because he's like you
said he hasn't played in three or four
years a lot has changed in the game the
way the game is being played right now
and you want to find out from him you
want to sit down with him and find out
where his mindset is because as a
quarterback in the NFL you have to be
kind of all-in especially if you're
trying to get a job and trying to
recreate yourself in the league it's not
like he's established guy and he can
maybe start doing some things off the
field he's trying to get back into it so
he's got to really be focused and all in
on this because more so than any other
position in sports quarterback you
better be all-in or it's not gonna work
well for you so that would be my biggest
question to him does he really want to
play football and then Kenny can he pass
the work out of what a team would put
him through and then is he gonna be
focused enough to get up to speed to
learn a team system because Cam Newton
is sitting out there right now and he's
not a starter Jameis Winston is a backup
somewhere this guy hasn't played in four
years so if he expects to come in and be
a starter that's not gonna happen he's
gonna have to work his way back in like
some of the other guys who have been
playing each and every week I was
reading a column by Charles Robinson on
Yahoo saying Roger Goodell has a small
window to save his legacy and have a
team sign Colin Kaepernick how does the
Commissioner convince a team to sign
Colin Kaepernick I don't understand this
yeah I don't know what that's gonna
happen either he has a lot of power but
I don't think he has that type of power
because again he works for the owners
and the owners kind of make the
decisions on how they want to do things
and and you know there's got to be an
owner out there that's willing to to to
take that opportunity to sign him I know
the Seahawks had him in here number
years ago and sat him down and they and
I think they got a chance to learn who
he was they got a chance to see him
physically and they put him you know
that was kind of part of their scouting
process that if we needed a quarterback
we knew this is a guy that maybe we
could go to so they know who he is
they've sat down with him and I think
this would be a good fit for him if
again he answers those other questions
we talked about whether he can pass the
workout and whether he's really totally
into playing football because Pete
Carroll's is open minded a coach that
there is in the league and the same
thing with the ownership up here so I
think it could work up here but again
those other questions have to be
answered
he's Warren Moon the CFL and NFL Hall of
Famer you're the only player in both CFL
and NFL Hall of Fame is that right I am
and only one other coach I think Bud
Grant but grant is a coach in the Olive
Eamon in Canada and also in the NFL - so
what are you forgoing you get a jacket
for going into the CFL Holton I do I got
a jacket and a bust kind of the same
thing yeah a better looking jacket
Canton or the Hamilton College the
jacket might look better in Canada
because it's black it's kind of hard to
wear your pro football you love you that
you have one in your closet but it's not
something you know you're gonna wear a
swag every week yet you know yeah it's
hard to have an outfit that goes along
with that that gold jacket there and
then what's your number inside on your
Pro Football Hall of Fame jacket
I think I'm 283 283 yeah that was when
Tony Dungy showed me that that was
really cool when you see that number in
there that inside patch it's pretty cool
you are the yeah you know exactly where
you stand in the history of the game
your salary first year in the CFL was
what 1978 I got thirty five thousand to
sign my hand and my first year salary
was forty five thousand Wow and that was
considered like a equivalent to a second
around contract in the NFL well you had
that money would go long way in Edmonton
well but I was living in Seattle at the
time but when I first came to the NFL
and I was like a true free agent and
highest-paid player in the league when I
came into the league I signed for five
years for five point five million Wow
but he changed they changed a little
since then but didn't you have a
contract that you were always going to
be one of the I forget what it was but
didn't you get raises depending on other
quarterbacks getting raises did did your
agent and negotiate that where you were
always going to be in the top five in
salary
yeah my second contract was like that
yeah it was called adjustable years so
nice nobody could ever be paid more than
myself and I I imagine something like
that would happen to today you look at
like a dak Prescott who's worried about
you know his contract or or Patrick
mahomes who probably is gonna be one of
the top quarterbacks from here going
forward you would think they'd want to
have something like that and their deal
if it's allowed some of those things
aren't allowed anymore but if that was
allowed do you know if this is true that
the story is LeBron James met his agent
rich Paul because rich was wearing a
Warren Moon Jersey and he rich was
walking through an airport LeBron
stopped him and asked him where he got
the jersey did you ever hear that story
yeah I heard that story yeah and the
next time I ever seen LeBron I'm gonna
mention that to him see if it's really
true why did you pick one you know it
was a number to me that was different it
was in my mind the number one is
something I always strived for to be the
best and then I also felt like as as my
teammates looked at me as the leader on
a team that number one is going to
always remind them if that's what we
want to be as a team as well so it has
significance as far as where I want to
finish personally and where our team
should want to finish as a team were you
there when Renfro Mike run throw the
game against the Steelers Lennie was not
there yet okay
yeah because Houston had some tough
losses and you know that Renfro catch
they say
wasn't a catch that was against
Pittsburgh right yeah yeah yeah I
watched that game up in Canada I think I
was up there at the time because Earl
Campbell when I came out the same year
and he went to he went to Houston as
their number one overall pick but I went
to Canada so I watched a lot of Houston
all of our games on television man Earl
was something different though but
that's that style though I mean we see
Derrick Henry now but Earl took on
everybody yeah and everybody in the
stadium knew he was getting the ball
pretty much every play and he still
couldn't be stopped but when I got to
Houston it was about his sixth year he
was a little bit banged up by then and
he ended up getting traded the next year
to New Orleans with bum Phillips because
he went to New Orleans but I saw
glimpses of who earl still was during
that one year that i played with him
when a happy year scuse me and it's
still one of those highlights doesn't he
hit Isiah Robertson of the Rams right in
the sternum ends right through and
almost it's good to talk to you Warren I
hope you're doing well we appreciate
your perspective on all of this and
thanks for joining us I'm doing great
now I'm glad you're doing as well and
look forward to talking to you down the
road Thank You Warren
that's a Warren Moon five great cups for
and pro football and the Canadian
Football Hall of Fame there